millions of americans are receiving
stimulus checks worth up to fourteen
hundred dollars each
you might be one of them it's all part
of president biden's 1.9 trillion dollar
american rescue plan
the american rescue plan is already
doing what it was designed to do
make a difference in people's everyday
lives
but you might have also heard people say
that if all that money gets spent
the economy will overheat and we'll get
inflation
in this video we'll answer the question
of whether stimulus checks will lead to
inflation
short answer it could but not
necessarily
and the reason is that the link between
stimulus checks and inflation
isn't direct there's a lot of other
things going on at the same time
first of all not all of the checks are
going to be spent
some people who didn't lose their jobs
and are doing pretty well will save them
money instead you know
put it in their 401k or they'll use the
money to pay off their credit card bills
or
other debts so if that money doesn't get
spent then it won't generate economic
activity and it therefore will not cause
any inflation
however some people will spend the
checks perhaps on new furniture or a car
or on a trip or they could use it to pay
more for their rent or groceries
and remember this isn't the only
spending going on there's also billions
of dollars being sent out by the federal
government as additional unemployment
insurance
they're also sending out money for state
and local governments
there's money being sent out to help
small businesses hold on to or hire
workers
also people have a lot of savings stored
up from last year's stimulus bills as
well and just waiting for the virus to
end
and for businesses to reopen so they can
go out and spend that money
and when that happens businesses will
need to go out and hire back a lot of
the workers who got laid off last year
so there will be a lot of spending and
hiring going on not just because of the
stimulus checks but for other reasons
too
but will that be enough to overheat the
economy
let's step back for a moment and ask how
overheating takes place
inflation happens when the demand for
goods and services
runs ahead of the economy's capacity to
supply those goods and services
with its current labor force think of
the economy's capacity like a container
demand is like water going into that
container if people go out
and spend their stimulus checks that
starts to fill up the container
businesses go out and hire workers who
go out and spend their paychecks
and that also helps to fill the
container but there's millions of
workers out of a job
thousands of businesses that are idle so
we can have lots of spending and lots of
hiring without the economy running out
of capacity
or the container filling up with water
not until the container overflows
do you get inflation now you may have
noticed that the prices for some things
are already going up
for airline tickets and gasoline and
lumber that's not really inflation
inflation is when most prices are going
up not just a few
and when they're going up year after
year what you're seeing right now
are just one time only price increases
in industries that have specific
bottlenecks
so right now the stimulus checks are
probably not going to cause inflation
here's why remember what i said about
the economy being like a container
well the container is still a long way
from being full there are more than 9
million
fewer people with jobs now than before
the pandemic
it's a lot of slack in the labor market
and it's going to take a lot of spending
a lot of hiring over many many months
before we start to run out of workers
economists don't really know how much
capacity the economy has
it's like they don't know how big the
container is we might run the water long
enough to fill the container
and discover that the container has
stretched and gotten bigger
in other words we may think we can only
get the unemployment rate down to say
four percent and then we'll run out of
workers but maybe as unemployment
goes down we'll find a lot more people
coming into the labor force to look for
jobs
one final point inflation is partly
psychological
businesses are more likely to raise
prices and wages if they think everyone
else will do the same thing
in other words if they expect higher
inflation they'll act
in a way that makes higher inflation
more likely but inflation has been low
for years
in fact it's too low the federal reserve
targets two percent
which they think is ideal inflation has
been so low for so long
people will assume it will stay that way
so i just explained why the stimulus
checks aren't likely to produce
inflation soon
but maybe in a few years we'll get
inflation how would that happen
well if we succeed in vaccinating most
of the country the virus will go away
and most of the economy will reopen so
people will start spending again
big time and maybe those stimulus checks
won't be the last
of the stimulus president biden is
talking about a big infrastructure
package
it's uh not only creates jobs but it
makes us a lot more competitive
around the world if we have the best
infrastructure in the world so in a year
or two
unemployment could fall close to three
percent for the first time in half a
century
that would look like a labor market that
has run out of slack
like the container has started to
overflow
there's one important reason why we
haven't had high inflation in a long
time
the federal reserve didn't let it happen
as soon as it thought the economy was
overheating because
unemployment was low it raised interest
rates
and often that put us into a recession
but jerome powell the chairman of the
fed
says this time is different because
inflation has been below 2
for so long powell wants inflation to
actually go above 2
for a while that's why he's keeping
interest rates at zero
that's why he plans to keep them close
to zero until 2024
at least we're not done and i'd hate to
see us take our eye off the ball before
we actually
finish the job there's another thing
that's different for a long time
all the politicians and the experts said
keeping inflation low should be the
priority
not any longer now presidents congress
and the fed
say low unemployment especially for
disadvantaged groups is more important
so even if inflation starts to look like
a problem maybe the fed will be
reluctant to raise interest rates
also those stimulus checks that's not
really free money
the government borrowed it and as a
result the national debt is sky high
if the fed raised interest rates to
fight inflation paying the interest on
that debt quickly gets very expensive
so if the fed ever decides it needs to
raise interest rates there will be a lot
of politicians hoping it doesn't
and maybe pressuring it not too
you